what kind of jobs do you think GPT
language models would
be better than humans at like full like
does the whole thing end to end better
not not not like what it's doing with
you where it's helping you be maybe 10
times more productive
those are both good questions I don't
I would say they're equivalent to me
because if I'm 10 times more productive
wouldn't that mean that there'll be a
need for much fewer programmers in the
world I think the world is going to find
out that if you can have 10 times as
much code at the same price you can just
use even more so write even more code
just needs way more code it is true that
a lot more could be digitized
there could be a lot more code and a lot
more stuff
I think there's like a supply issue yeah
so in terms of really replace jobs is
that a worry for you
it is uh I'm trying to think of like a
big category that I believe
can be massively impacted I guess I
would say
customer service is a category that I
could see
there are just way fewer jobs relatively
soon
I'm not even certain about that
but I could believe it
so like uh basic questions about when do
I take this pill if it's a drug company
or what when uh I don't know who I went
to that but like how do I use this
product like questions yeah like how do
I use whatever whatever call center
employees are doing now yeah this does
not work yeah okay
I I want to be clear I think like these
systems will
make
a lot of jobs just go away every
technological Revolution does they will
enhance many jobs and make them much
better much more fun much higher paid
and
and they'll create new jobs that are
difficult for us to imagine even if
we're starting to see the first glimpses
of them but
um I heard someone last week talking
about gbt4 saying that you know man uh
the Dignity of work is just such a huge
deal we've really got to worry like even
people who think they don't like their
jobs they really need them it's really
important to them into society
and also can you believe how awful it is
that France is trying to raise the
retirement age
and I think we as a society are confused
about whether we want to work more or
work less
and certainly about whether most people
like their jobs and get value out of
their jobs or not some people do I love
my job I suspect you do too
that's a real privilege not everybody
gets to say that if we can move more of
the world to better jobs and work to
something that can be
a broader concept not something you have
to do to be able to eat but something
you do is a creative expression and a
way to find fulfillment and happiness
whatever else even if those jobs look
extremely different from the jobs of
today
I think that's great I'm not I'm not
nervous about it at all
you have been a proponent of Ubi
Universal basic income in the context of
AI can you describe your philosophy
there of of our human future with Ubi
why why you like it what are some
limitations I think it is a component
of something we should pursue it is not
a full solution I think people work for
lots of reasons besides money
um
and I think we are going to find
incredible new jobs and society as a
whole and people's individuals are going
to get much much richer but as a cushion
through a dramatic transition and as
just like
you know I think the world should
eliminate poverty if able to do so I
think it's a great thing to do
um as a small part of the bucket of
solutions I helped start a project
called World coin
um
which is a technological solution to
this we also have funded a uh like a
large I think maybe the the largest most
comprehensive Universal basic income
study as part of sponsored by openai
and I think it's like an area we should
just be be looking into
what are some like insights from that
study that you gain we're going to
finish up at the end of this year and
we'll be able to talk about it hopefully
early very early next if we can Linger
on it how do you think the economic and
political systems will change
as AI becomes a prevalent part of
society it's such an interesting sort of
philosophical question
uh looking 10 20 50 years from now
what does the economy look like
what does politics look like do you see
significant transformations in terms of
the way democracy functions even
I love that you asked them together
because I think they're super related I
think the the economic transformation
will drive much of the political
transformation here not the other way
around
um
my working model for the last
five years has been that
the two dominant changes will be that
the cost of intelligence and the cost of
energy are going over the next couple of
decades to dramatically dramatically
fall from where they are today
and the impact of that and you're
already seeing it with the way you now
have like peop you know programming
Ability Beyond what you had as an
individual before
is society gets much much richer much
wealthier in ways that are probably hard
to imagine I think every time that's
happened before it has been
that economic impact has had positive
political impact as well and I think it
does go the other way too like the the
socio-political values of the
Enlightenment enabled the
long-running technological Revolution
and and scientific discovery process
we've had for
the past centuries
um
but I think we're just going to see more
I'm sure the shape will change
but I think it's just long and beautiful
exponential curve
do you think there will be more
um
I don't know what the the term is but
systems that resemble something like
Democratic socialism I've talked to a
few folks on this podcast about these
kinds of topics Instinct yes I hope so
so that it
reallocate some resources in a way that
supports kind of lifts the
the people who are struggling I am a big
believer in lift up the floor and don't
worry about the ceiling
if I can uh test your historical
knowledge it's probably not gonna be
good but let's try it
why do you think I come from the Soviet
Union why do you think communism in the
Soviet Union failed I recoil at the idea
of living
in a communist system
and I don't know how much of that it's
just the biases of the world I've grow
up in and what I have been taught and
probably more than I realize
but I think like more
individualism more human will more
ability to self-determine
um
is important
and also
I think the ability to try new things
and not need permission and not need
some sort of central planning
betting on human Ingenuity and this sort
of like distributed process
I believe is always going to beat
centralized planning
and I think that like for all of the
deep flaws of America I think it is the
greatest place in the world
because it's the best at this
so it's really interesting uh that
centralized planning failed some soul in
such big ways
but what if hypothetically the
centralized planning it was a perfect
super intelligent AGI super intelligent
AGI
again in my goal
wrong in the same kind of ways but it
might not and we don't really know
we don't really know it might be better
I expect it would be better but would it
be better than
a hundred super intelligent or a
thousand super intelligent agis sort of
in a liberal democratic system arguing
yes
um now also how much of that can happen
internally in one super intelligent AGI
not so obvious
there is something about right but there
is something about like tension the
competition but you don't know that's
not happening inside one model yeah
that's true
it'd be nice
it would be nice if whether it's
engineered in or revealed to be
happening it'd be nice for it to be
happening that then of course it can
happen with multiple agis talking to
each other or whatever
there's something also about uh I mean
still Russell has talked about the
control problem of um
always having AGI to be have some degree
of uncertainty
not having a dogmatic certainty to it
that feels important
so some of that is already handled with
human alignment uh uh human feedback
reinforcement learning with human
feedback but it feels like there has to
be engineered in like a hard uncertainty
humility you can put a romantic word to
it yeah
anything that's possible to do
the definition of those words I think
the details really matter but is I
understand them yes I do